[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah Thursday Thursday
we made it
almost to Friday you know what Friday is
bonehead of the week you're gonna vote
tonight for bonehead of the week
tomorrow
we'll do it in the second hour
whoosh there's a lot of boneheads this
week I am going to show you a couple
videos of some absolute boneheads today
um one of them is a voter in Georgia
um
I'm not sure exactly and I think it was
maybe Von Hilliard who's doing the
interview with this guy I'm not sure I
think it was on MSNBC this guy said he's
he voted for Herschel Walker uh but
Warnock is a way better gay but you know
he's a republican he must vote
Republican
this is what we're up against
they're gonna vote for they're gonna
vote for just the shittiest candidates
they're gonna do it
they're going to vote for the shitty
candidates
because they've been geared to vote for
Republican this guy even says I'm a
business owner
I'm a business as if as if Herschel
Walker somehow going to the United
States Senate is good for any business
owner
it's really [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
but it's not surprising
that a republican who votes Republican
especially for a candidate like Herschel
Walker would say some stupid [ __ ]
why am I talking about this this morning
well I'm nursing a hangover and I don't
have much more the important thing is is
that Herschel Walker should not be a
United States Senator
that is the most important thing right
now in this moment I know there's a lot
of distractions there's the Elon brain
chip
I called it the simp chip this morning
you've seen the uh the title
hmm
I wonder if the brain chip comes with a
red pill I don't know just saying
we called it the death chip well that's
um
your
your great co-host Gabe Sanchez came up
with the uh with the thumbnail the dead
chip so we're gonna talk today of course
um about elon's
microchip you know
it's the same people who were voting for
Herschel Walker who are excited
about having Elon planning a chip in
their brain when for three years they
have been yelling and screaming
on Facebook Q Anon groups
um fake Gabe included probably about
halifaxine has a chip in it you remember
the Magneto part of the timeline do you
remember that
do you remember this
remember wait oh my god it feels like
decades ago
do you remember the Magneto part
these [ __ ] were going to like
City Council meetings and [ __ ] and and
putting Quarters on themselves
quarters that aren't [ __ ] that isn't
magnetic and like sticking it to
themselves you remember this like out
makes me magnetic and then they put a
piece of metal that's not magnetic on
them and it sticks to them because they
haven't taken a [ __ ] shower in a year
that
there was the Magneto part of the
timeline
you remember this right I'm not crazy I
know I know this is a real thing
it went on for a couple weeks and we
mocked them we mocked the [ __ ] out of
them
and they finally gave up the Magneto
thing but these same people the same
it's same [ __ ]
who believed that they were magnetic
because they got the vaccine and
quarters were sticking to them
same [ __ ] are gonna get the
brain chip from Elon they're going to
chip themselves I guess that's the
difference right
your pro you know your pro-choice your
pro chip right any of your and and look
I'm all for Liberty right if you want to
have Elon
implant a death chip into your brain
fine whatever right like I'm I'm not
gonna you know what am I gonna do
right yeah what am I gonna do
that's that's your [ __ ] right I'm not
you know I'm gonna [ __ ] mock the [ __ ]
out of you just like just like you're
paying eight dollars for Twitter
same [ __ ]
and you can see them anyone who's paying
eight bucks for Twitter more than likely
is gonna get the [ __ ] Elon chip
but it's the same [ __ ] that are
voting for Herschel Walker how is this a
how are we in such a weird [ __ ] state
of History
foreign
some [ __ ] who are going to get the
Elon ship bitched about being chipped
from the vaccine are the same
[ __ ] that are voting for all
Republicans
just because they're Republican
that's where we're at that's I mean we
are at the intersection of WrestleMania
and real life
we're there we are there folks we've
been there for a while I've been saying
it for a long time
here on the Tony Michaels podcast
WrestleMania and real life
you can't
you can't imagine the stupidity
that these people are going to
absolutely
bear before us right in front of our
eyes
there's no amount of imagination
no amount of imagination
that can make the story any weirder
any
any less stupid
I mean q Anon is a hell of a drug and
it's a q Anon World we're just living in
it folks
so I guess there's that but here's what
I do want to say about the Hershel
Walker I think this is very important
it's it's super important that Warnock
pull this one out I I I have a lot of
confidence like I said I was confident
about the midterms I'm very confident
about this runoff seeing the numbers
that were there beforehand
um because in a runoff that's basically
the numbers that are going to manifest
because in the Georgia runoff apparently
you have to had voted in the in the
midterm election
to revoke
in the runoff
so Warnock
beat him handily
but because of how the races work in
Georgia he didn't quite get 50 so it's
an automatic runoff
and we've done this before right at the
runoff that is we did it in 2020
and Trump ruined it
ruined it for loffler
and Purdue
you remember that absolutely ruined it
and really they're ruining it now
because people like Carrie Laker saying
you can't trust machines you can't trust
the voting machines you can't vote it's
voting is not it's not it's you can't
trust it
they're wanting a new election in
Arizona
I wonder how long it'll take Herschel
Walker to realize that he actually has
another election
I don't know that maybe they've
convinced him that he's already a
senator it's possible
um he's still doing uh interviews from
his house in Texas
that house that you see you know what
the the weird staircase behind him
that's in Texas apparently that's where
he lives
so
there's that that's not abnormal for
Republican Senators my Republican
senator does not live in Missouri
he hasn't lived in Missouri for a long
time Josh Hawley
he does not live in Missouri hasn't
lived here for a long time even when he
was the Attorney General he had to rent
a house in the capital city
just so he could be Attorney General
of the state of Missouri but he he lives
in Virginia he does not live in Missouri
so it's not abnormal for a Republican
senator not to live in the state in
which they are a senator same thing with
Ted Cruz guy lives in Cancun apparently
the senator of Texas not a prime example
so I guess the people of Georgia are
going to make a decision here and I
believe it will be Warnock
I don't think we have much to worry
about but we have to engage we have to
lean into the Democracy like I said for
the midterm we have to concentrate it is
the focus
and there's a lot of news going on
there's the LeBron James
um video of Jerry Jones that's a
distraction we may look at that today I
doubt it
it's um it's it's a distraction again
I think it's important but it's a
distraction from the the key element
here which is 51 in the Senate the
reason why 51 in the Senate is so
important
is because of the subpoena power and
really the Committees
um we don't have to share power
with 51. with 50 50 you kind of there's
a shared agreement that goes on with the
power in the Senate
but with 51 there is no [ __ ] shared
power
it's not Mitch McConnell is handicapped
he's not in power at all he is in the
minority
so which that's where Mitch McConnell
belongs is in the minority in the Senate
now rather he's the leadership or not I
guess they'll decide I think he's got
the votes in the Senate
which brings us back to why it is so
important that that Herschel Walker lose
in Georgia and Warnock is still our
senator in Georgia
the reason why it's so important
is because you're gonna have the crazies
in the house right and you may you may
you just may need subpoena power
the full subpoena power
when you have
ridiculous Q Anon
representatives in the House Republicans
only talking about some dude's laptop
and shutting down the government
sometime next year that's probably what
they're going to do
so we we need to have a backstop it is
super important so if you are in Georgia
you know someone Georgia here's the
great news the great news is is the
turnout so far in the early vote is is
apparently more
than it was for the actual midterm
people are [ __ ] voting baby
this is great I I can't tell you
and I've said it a lot here on the show
that gen Z
is it is the generation that is going to
save democracy it it it it truly is and
I I know that some people would love
to be part of the generation that would
save democracy but we can encourage them
um it is incredible what they're going
to do they understand the assignment
right fully full stop they understand
the assignment
rather it be the midterm whether it be
this runoff they truly get democracy and
they truly know how to engage uh young
folks in the past they get excited right
they have a lot of opinions
they protest a lot a lot of protests are
younger folks
but this gen Z
yes they take their politics seriously
it ain't just about showing up with the
sign
it's about it's about absolutely
getting to the ballot
and making sure to have your voice heard
and I don't know how it came to be
that with Gen Z voting became sexy but
that is a thing we need to continue
it is a and and because politics
generally isn't sexy right it's not a
sexy thing it's not that entertaining
but maybe just maybe
maybe just maybe
we we should
give credit where credit is due the
Cheeto dust q and honor he brought us to
WrestleMania in real life that
intersection
and gen Z is now activating I said in
2015 when he originally came down the
escalator I said
if Donald Trump becomes president which
I didn't believe he would be at that
time I didn't think he'd get enough
votes
I really didn't now he he he went on a
technicality he lost by three million in
the popular vote
which was
most people knew he was going to lose
the popular vote he's a [ __ ] loser no
one likes the guy but the point is
is that I felt like back then the same
way Lindsey Graham did
that if Donald Trump becomes the
president it will absolutely rip apart
the Republican party but never in my
wildest dreams never in my wildest
dreams
did I imagine
that this fascist
this this [ __ ] Silver Spoon fascist
would would activate an entire
generation never never in my wildest
dreams
never
but he did he absolutely did because
they know they know the stakes they know
it
with Nick Fuentes a [ __ ] Nazi
Milo yiannopoulos another [ __ ] not
and Kanye West going to have dinner with
Donald Trump and he can't
he can't utter the words
that he condemns them
he's just like I don't know who I don't
know who that Nazi is I have no idea I
I'm the real Nazi I don't know who this
Nick Fuentes is I don't know who he
thinks he is
he can't condemn him and really honestly
the entire Republican party can't
condemn the [ __ ] and I've got a video I
want to show you today because
there is reason to believe
and again I've said it time and time
that Nick Fuentes is the messaging
machine of the Republican party that's
where they're getting it where do you
think the America First [ __ ] comes from
his his organization is called America
burst
Nazis but here's the thing is that there
are other people out there that are in
that Universe of Nick Fuentes and
they're they're ha they're so happy
they're so happy that he dined
with Trump but that's what's activating
gen Z
don't you see it
with the Republican Party saying the
quiet part out loud and really
embodying the quiet part
that they've always held close to their
vest
now it's out in the open they know and
they know and that's what's activating
gen Z
that's why that's why they're so engaged
in politics because they can see the
risk it's not
you know you don't need much nuance
to understand
that these people are [ __ ] dangerous
that their ideas are dangerous I mean
look what happened in Colorado
with Club Q
if you don't if you don't believe that
people like Nick Fuentes Matt Walsh
Tucker Carlson
have blood on their hands you're not
paying attention
you're not paying attention
and rounding back to the Senate this is
why it is so important
that we have Reverend Warnock in the
Senate
is for
bills like the respective Marriage Act
Because he believes in Liberty
and he doesn't believe in stripping
people of their rights just because of
who they are
it's a really funny thing that
the Christians in Georgia are voting for
The Gang who's
you know held his held his wife at
gunpoint beat the hell out of people
played Russian Roulette threatened
people with his gun
forced women to get abortions
paid for abortions which you know I'm
not against
that the Christians are voting for him
instead of the Reverend
the actual man who has walked
the walk
of Christianity right
who's lived
the word of the book they claim to love
so much
and here they are voting for the
opposite of that
because again Q Anon is a hell of a drug
but that is why we must get Warnock
across the line so if you are thinking
right now
that you want to give to Democrats the
place to give if it's anything five
dollars ten dollars twenty dollars the
place to probably do that right now the
most effective place to give for
democracy right now is directly
to Reverend Warnock
that's probably the place
if you're gonna give your time and
energy to a campaign
which it's really the only campaign
going
it's it's Warnock
because that that senate seat
even though we still have without it we
still have 50 in the Senate 51.
is what is going to make the next two
years count because we can count
on the House Republicans to be in
disarray
to be absolutely incoherent
to be absolutely focusing on some dude's
laptop
it is a thing that will happen
so you got the choice
you've got the choice
you can lean into democracy and we can
pull Warnock Over The Line
which the the lines are long down there
the vote
should scare the [ __ ] out of these
Republicans in the Senate I think they
know what's coming though don't you
don't you think
surely surely they know this is not
going to go well for them right after
the midterms are they this confident
can they be will they I don't know I
don't think they should be
they got their asses clobbered the only
reason why they have the house in the
first place is because how they
gerrymandered the districts that's it
and they barely have it maybe maybe by
four
Maybe
Maybe
hell they can't even get their their
leader
Kevin McCarthy over the finish line
right now to 218.
so we shall see we shall see but I will
tell you that we will not stop talking
about our democracy here on the Tony
Michaels podcast every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch you know today's Thursday right
tomorrow is Friday and you guys know
what happens on Friday at the Tony
Michael's podcast we have bonehead of
the week and if you're a new listener
here's what happens with bone of the
week you go vote you decide who is the
bone of the week and me and my co-host
Gabe Sanchez break it down every single
Friday in the second hour so don't
forget to vote on YouTube subscribe
right now if you have not already hit
that button you go to the community tab
on our YouTube channel that's where the
bone hint of the week poll lives and as
long as I don't get Perma band
from Twitter today which I'm I'm talking
about elon's uh death chip his brain
chip same stupid [ __ ] that are
gonna vote for Herschel Walker want to
get a chip and planted in their head by
Elon Musk this is the same guy that
makes [ __ ] dumpster fire cars have
you seen this these these Teslas act
they just
they just come they just
combust into flames
is burn up and you're gonna want that
guy to put a [ __ ] chip in your head I
don't think so but it's the same
[ __ ] so I'm bound to get
permaband from Twitter because we're
talking about it on elon's Twitter today
but as long as we're still there it's at
Tony Michael's pod that's where you can
find the bone of the week pole so go
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod you can also download every single
episode here at the Tony Michaels
podcast on Apple Spotify and Google make
sure to leave a great review while
you're subscribing there also someone
noticed my hoodie yesterday
you notice my the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
they noticed my hoodie yesterday in
public
and they said where do I get one of
those I gave them the website and here's
the website
store.thetonymichaels.com
store.thetonymichaels.com we've got
hoodies zip up hoodies sweatshirts
t-shirts
we even got it on coffee mugs and don't
forget why you're there to stop and look
at the Ron DeSantis King go [ __ ] himself
this is going to be great you're going
to want to have this
for your relatives this Christmas
especially the ones from Florida you
want to get the Ron DeSantis can go [ __ ]
himself merge for all your family in
Florida for the holiday season go to
store.thetonymichaels.com that's
store.thetonymichaels.com you are the
best audience in the world I am so glad
you're joining us on this Thursday even
though I'm nursing a bit of a hangover
um I'm not gonna lie I had a view too
many last night it happens what are you
gonna do I needed to kill some brain
cells for crying out loud
I'm glad you're joining me today though
I am happy that you're here because I am
and we will be right back right after
these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
[Music]
who else is gonna get the Eight dollar
brain chip you think it's eight bucks I
don't know
seems to every eight dollars to see
where this gang lands look
when you're pricing things for retail
right you want to you want it to have a
nicer ring to it that's why Twitter blue
was five bucks and really all he's done
and we've talked about it here all he's
done is just raise the price of Twitter
blue right it's not even [ __ ]
different I mean you get the little
check mark now but it's not any [ __ ]
different
other than he charges you three dollars
more for Twitter blue
but in retail you're trying to have a
nice nice number right like 10.
ten ten dollars
ten dollars even though it's two more
dollars is much better than eight
dollars I'm just saying that's a better
marketing strategy
I gave Elon way too much credit
I really did I thought
I thought that he would totally make
sure that he would not buy Twitter I
thought he was smart enough to realize
this he is not
he's not smart enough to realize this
but it makes sense now it really it's it
it all is becoming clear
is that isn't it
obviously he obviously is not smart
enough to know to not buy Twitter
and it's because he is one of them
like he is one of these [ __ ] crypto
Bros that's in your [ __ ] threads
that's talking all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
makes no sense right you know what I'm
talking about
these [ __ ] trolls they get up in your
thread and you're like who is this
person and why are they saying the [ __ ]
they're saying it makes no sense I know
vaccines have a chip in it oh Elon
elon's got the good chip though they're
going to literally the same
[ __ ]
that that wouldn't get the vaccine
because it has some kind of [ __ ]
microchip in it which it doesn't
are going to intentionally get chipped
by Elon Musk
but he is one of them like he he
believes this [ __ ] about the Jeep right
like I I would imagine that if you talk
to Elon Musk about the vaccine and about
microchips being in the vaccine and [ __ ]
like the Magneto thing I was talking
about earlier do you remember this right
I remember this clearly clearly remember
for two weeks these [ __ ]
believe that quarters were sticking to
them because they were magnetic because
they got the vaccine quarters are not
magnetic by the way
they they were going in front of cameras
and microphones and putting [ __ ]
Quarters on themselves and [ __ ] like
look it's sticking to me yeah dummy take
a [ __ ] showery nasty bastard
like you're [ __ ] sticky
you need you need a little bit of soap
and some Suds to wash off the [ __ ] that
you the quarters sticking to man
it was really [ __ ] dumb but he's one
of them Elon I'm telling you he is one
of them he believes this [ __ ] there's no
one around him that is gonna whip him
into shape and get him into a situation
where he has to [ __ ] come to grips
with reality like this guy lives in a
total alternate universe
a total alternate universe
that that anything is real as long as
you want to believe it I mean [ __ ] he's
even said it he he's basically saying
that's what free speech is
and again
if you can say whatever the [ __ ] you
want in this country to a certain extent
and it's free speech you're not free
from the consequences we talked about
this before
but it's the same dumb [ __ ]
that believe that they get to say
whatever they want without any
consequence they're white dudes they get
to say whatever they want without any
consequence whatsoever that is their
right because they're white and they're
dudes that is their ability and their
right to say whatever they want without
consequence they're the same
[ __ ] that were like yeah you're
gonna get a chip in in the vaccine and
they're gonna track you literally are
going to line up to pay eight dollars to
get a brain chip implanted in them so
Elon can track them
what the [ __ ]
this is the thing and it's probably I
don't know he apparently he's Banning
um
he's suspending accounts today that that
are talking about this
you know basically how dumb this brain
chip is so I'm I'm like I don't know
maybe I'll get suspended I mean you know
we should try for it at least
I don't know if I'm suspended yet or not
is this broadcast going out on Twitter I
don't know
I don't know but uh Gabe Sanchez is
going to join us in a minute if he's
listening
and we're going to talk about this dead
chip but the other thing I want to talk
about in the shitless Roundup
is
um Prager University I don't know if you
know who this is Prager but he was
talking about again these [ __ ] right
Wingers like Matt Walsh and Ben Shapiro
Tucker Carlson they cannot stop thinking
they can't stop thinking about other
people's genitalia they just can't it's
like an obsession I wonder why but um
yesterday I watched the clip
hey oh my God you You're gonna laugh at
this
but they're saying that liberals only
want trans women to dress sexy I don't
know what the hell that's about
really the thing that we want as
liberals is just if someone wants to
dress the way they want to dress
whatever
you want to do and it doesn't make us if
you're not telling me how to dress
then I don't give a [ __ ] I really don't
care how you dress if you're if you're
not telling me how to dress that's fine
with me so we're gonna watch that video
that's some crazy [ __ ] we're gonna watch
the video of the the Herschel Walker
voter who thinks Warnock is the better
person I'm not [ __ ] you said this
[ __ ] into a microphone
um also there's news out of the fifth
Circuit Court uh covers Louisiana Texas
the federal uh Circuit Court in the
fifth
and apparently they struck down the
the student loan forgiveness this is
really stupid too I don't understand why
why would you challenge this that's the
question
that you know anyone with student loan
debt that's going to get some relief
here which is not relief at all in the
grand scheme of things if you think
about it right I mean a lot of people
are pissed off it wasn't more than 10
000 or 20 depending on your situation
and depending on how much money you do
or don't have or how much you do or
don't make
but
when you're talking about this student
loan forgiveness right most most of that
ten thousand is barely going to cover
the interest that you've paid
right if you go back and you look at
those amortization schedules of the
student loan and you look at how much
interest how much principal you had it's
not even going to cover the entirety of
the interest that you paid on those
[ __ ] student loans this idea that
somehow someone's getting something for
free is [ __ ] dumb
it's really ridiculous because they've
already paid interest and they're going
to pay more interest than the relief
they're getting and these Republicans
because they're all Republicans that do
not want you to get your relief from
your student loans remember these are
the [ __ ] who yell and scream
and back gas prices gas prices this melt
prices that [ __ ] you know
everything's inflation inflation
inflation gym I don't report sex crimes
Jordan yelling and screaming about it
for months and now now in the fifth
circuit because of Republicans challenge
to the president of the United States
saying hey I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
spot you ten thousand bucks
which is just a fraction
of your interest
right just a fraction of your interest
now the fifth circuit's telling you to
[ __ ] off because of Republicans keeps
inches
I know you got opinions on this
um with the student debt relief
um
and it's it's really weird that we have
to um sit here and talk about how a
particular political party it's a and it
is a particular political party right
trying to make sure that you don't get
relief from the interest that you paid
on your loans because again this ten
thousand bucks I I know you had a lot of
student loans right I had students now
I'm a two-time College Dropout so I you
know I'm a loser I'm a loser I'm glad
student loans but I paid them off years
ago right right interest principle the
whole thing but really if you look at
someone who has a four-year degree or a
master's and you look at the amount of
debt that they actually that they
actually held the entire time and they
still have debt that that interest that
they paid on that debt is is way Far and
Beyond 10 grand yeah I mean there are
there are so many I mean even when I was
paying off my my student loans
you know the amount of it because you've
got you know like I think six months to
a year or so after you leave or after
you graduate whichever whichever one
comes first from school they say okay
great turn it on
and now you got to start okay you're
saying you're saying once you get out of
school they give you six months to get a
job and just start getting an income
they don't even care if you have a job
it's right you have to start paying so
it's either six months after the fact of
you leaving like you could just drop out
or you graduate whichever one comes
first and they say great I think it's
six months after the after that moment
the government is notified and they say
okay cool the timer's been set you have
six months to figure out whatever you
need to if you don't that's too bad you
could defer and try to you know say that
you don't have the income but that only
extends for so long
so yeah you've got a group like the
Republican party not like that you've
got a group that is the Republican party
and they are actively working against
helping people so let's say I I go for
the American dream I go get my college
education I say hey I want to get a job
because that's what it requires me to do
and then when I get out of school they
say okay you got to pay back these loans
great yes I I put myself into debt
because I was told a four-year or plus
education was what I needed to do for my
job
and then when it comes to time to pay
them and I can't pay them then
Republicans look it's like ah well that
[ __ ] sucks but I can't do anything
about it no you literally can and then
when when you've got President Biden who
says look I'm gonna relieve 10 to 20 000
depending on what your loans are
then I will I want to help you out now I
can't wipe it all out right if I could I
would but I can't wipe it all out so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna help you
from 10 to 20. most of the time it's
going to be 10K and you can save that
money and use it for other things and
Republicans like you just mentioned
before I came in they want to whine
about [ __ ] gas prices and inflation
all these other costs and you look at
all the social programs in addition
to paying off these student loan uh uh
payments or or these the these student
loans
Republicans do nothing they want to
block it they want to stop it they don't
want to give you any sort of Aid so
Democrats are the only ones that are
introducing social programs that are
supposed to be helping people and
Republicans are just looking around
being like well I didn't get any money
in my pocket so for that reason I'm out
like this is [ __ ] Shark Tank and
they're they're presenting a deal here
to say look we've got this idea and we
want to do this and we think it'll be
great and they're like ah but what do I
get out of it you get the fact that you
helped your constituents and you you
probably will get reelected like
it's just an insane thing I mean yeah
you've got you know Miss left speak here
says I want everyone that I got a few
people loaned for us to pay it back if I
can't have my student loan forgiveness
for 10K it's just like exactly you it's
this the same [ __ ] that are out
there trying to take away the program
that that gives you the interest on your
loan back right because that's what it
is folks 10 grand in the grand scheme of
things when you're talking about student
loans is not a lot of [ __ ] money it's
not it's not a lot of money it just
ain't it's sad that 10 grand isn't a lot
of money nowadays but it's not it's not
a lot of money especially when you're
talking about the interest because what
what is the um is the Congressional
interest it's almost six percent right
because Congress sets the interest
interest on the federal I don't know
what it was I believe I was saying like
the fixed rate yeah I I it's been a long
time since I actually uh let's see it's
been probably five or six years since I
paid off my student loans that's the
other thing it pisses me off too people
are like ah already paid all my student
loans they don't deserve it like what
the [ __ ] if you still had loans you'd
want it the [ __ ] 10 grand to you're
just mad that people aren't giving you
10 grand that it's relief from the
interest because that's truly what it is
it looks like it's almost six percent I
believe isn't it
if I look at these someone know what
their student loan federal student aid
Government website
uh subsidized loan subsidized and direct
unsubsidized loans for undergraduate
borrower type is 4.99 4.99 so it's
almost if you're in graduate or
professional it's 6.5 there it is so if
you're a parent and graduate or
professional students because there's
like the direct Plus Loans direct
unsubsidized directly right because
there's parent loans there's different
types of but here's the thing it's five
six percent right yeah and and those
interest rates are set by Congress and
they're fixed rates and really right now
and really during and during the
pandemic too is the only time that those
interest rates have been paused even if
because you know this you've talked
about this on the show if you put your
um your loans in forbearance they've
still built the [ __ ] interest it
didn't stop the [ __ ] right now is during
the pandemic and right now is the only
time that they pause that [ __ ] right and
and the president has paused it now
because the Republicans are trying to
rip away the [ __ ] interest that
literally the president United States is
saying hey I'm going to give you 10
grand of your money back that you paid
the government that we profited off of
that's literally what he's doing is he's
giving profit that the government made
on your ass for [ __ ] taking a student
loan right which the government tells
you go to college get a good [ __ ] job
blah blah blah blah which I'm not saying
that's right or wrong but the point is
the president United States is trying to
give back the money that the government
[ __ ] took from you as profit and it's
not even it's not even giving anyone
money and that's what probably yeah yeah
and because Republicans in America oh
where'd the money come from it's okay
look it was made up to begin with and
the idea that you're cutting 10 000 out
of the expense that you have to pay for
whatever that time frame is right
because you could be like oh 10K that's
you know a few months or 10K that could
be 11 months depending on what your
repayment plan is right it could be
longer than that I mean knowing interest
it's probably a shorter period but the
idea that you're like hey look 10K that
you would have spent
on these loans forget it focus on that
10K somewhere else in your life that you
really needed your rent your kids your
car whatever it might be
but that's what it is it's not like oh
we're giving you a 10K check because
that's what Republicans want to make it
sound like it's literally like look you
had 10K we said you owed 10K because
this interest rate and the tax again
it's all made up right the number as to
what college tuition should be is a
made-up number when you look at the
overall expendis the expenses of higher
education the school
not a lot of things change right when
you have an endowment when you have
private uh private lenders right you
have you have people who are like oh
well I'm an alumni and I'm going to give
you 10 million to build this building
right some of the money yes is coming
from college tuition but also you need
to remember that like year over year
when you've got College tuition that is
growing exponentially over inflation
then you know there's something wrong
within the higher education system and
you know you have to look at that and
say look if this if this chart right
here is the price of of tuition and it's
going like this in in inflation is is
steadily increasing this way and you
look at the Gap you have to understand
that there is a big problem right there
and so for anyone to look at that and
say oh no that's just it is what it is
no it's not it is what it is it's
literally trying to I mean you're you're
getting ripped off in many ways
depending what you're doing right well
and that's that's the other thing too
that is the fallacy here that morons
like fake Gabe and Jeremy Johnson which
they they're they're going to be
bitching about the student loan I would
love to hear what uh what college
education at uh Jeremy Johnson and fake
gave God I would love to know what
doctorate program they were easy into
easy on the easy on the Dropout because
I'm I'm I'm a teacher I'm out of it I'm
proud not at all I just I just say I I
would assume I would assume that fake
game for all the research that he does
like deep academic research absolutely
fake Gabe is probably like a PhD level
like he probably has he probably has a
degree like like Mike Lindell has that
uh congratulations certificate oh
certificate of excellence yeah but he's
probably got a degree from the Q and on
Facebook group uh The Binding librarian
makes another good point here that we
haven't quite uh edged to yet with the
student loan stuff she says Republicans
are also calling college grants who who
are paying on loans lazy um we're voters
maybe that's why you didn't get the
Senate and I I believe that's true and
that's the other crazy part about this
is that there are
I know someone personally who's going to
benefit from this
this relief
what is crazy about this person's
situation that I know is that they just
spent a [ __ ] ton of money adopting a
baby because they can't they can't have
one right on their own right they just
spent a shitload of money on adopting a
baby which
is the Republican thing right like an
adopted which is also insane that you
have to pay that like the the exorbitant
amounts of money to adopt a child that
someone's like look I can't care for
this kid we'd much rather have to go to
a family and then Republicans be like
we're not going to give you any relief
to do that no well the other thing too
is both both of these of these folks
our military veterans or active guard
right
they have student loans it's not a thing
where just because you're in the
military you get all your student loans
paid for that's not exactly how it works
this person has gotten several degrees
and has a job they're not lazy and they
are going to benefit from this relief
and the benefit wasn't like I'm getting
10 grand it was I just spent all this
money because we wanted a baby right
right we wanted to have a family
and that relief was going to give them
peace of mind that they wouldn't have to
continue paying interest because that is
exactly what they would be paying right
because they've already paid interest
for the last 15 years on these loans
because that's the thing if you go
through and you look at the amortization
schedule on like five six percent over
the 20 30 years it takes you to pay off
the [ __ ] hundreds of thousands of
dollars depending on where you go but
right now
let's be realistic I mean what's the
average
um four-year degree going to cost you 80
to 100 Grand I'm sure I mean it was much
less than what I was going to school but
it was much less that when we were in
school but now I mean you also have to
remember the average cost of a child
right now is two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars between the age of when
they were born to the age of 17 or 18.
so like that's something else where
you've got this now quarter million
which is just right now that doesn't
count in in you know next year's
inflation and so on and so on right and
not only that but then you've got a loan
and people under need to understand too
on the Republican side they were like oh
this [ __ ] yo this much money it's
just whatever you know pay it
it's almost like they don't understand
like what an interest rate is
so when you when you apply to a person
who thinks JFK Jr is still alive can you
imagine trying to [ __ ] explain
interest rates and amortization
schedules to a [ __ ] who believes
Michael Jackson is going to run with
Donald Trump this is crazy [ __ ] but
that's the point that I think uh
librarian My Librarian is 20 out here is
that these people they had they really
they talk about gas prices Jim I don't
report sex crime Jordan tweets about
inflation six times a day real America
real America and to be quite honest
these people that I know personally that
that will benefit
uh just in the actual peace of mind
about this student loan
just in the Peace of Mind the people who
benefit they're not [ __ ] lazy they're
not [ __ ] lazy they're far from it I I
feel lazy being around them to be quite
honest so like what do you do I'm like I
got this radio show I'm like Jesus
Christ you lazy bastard yeah I do it's
it's it's
I don't work that hard here I mean it is
work but it's not really but they work
really hard right
they work really hard like back breaking
labor type work and not easy [ __ ] yeah
and it's it's ridiculous that it's
ridiculous that an entire party like
librarian is saying is is putting is
putting all these voters in a position
where they have to make a consideration
like well do you really give a [ __ ]
about me but but but Gabe that is the
beautiful part about the Republican
party in this day and age and the reason
why we do this show is because we get
the point of map we get to point out the
quiet part that they are saying through
a [ __ ] Mega I mean if we really want
to call the people who are lazy out then
it would be the Republican party right
like they're the people who show up or
don't show up you know you've got
Madison cawthorne who missed the most
amount of votes in session uh during his
freshman year
but then you've got other people like uh
Lauren bobert Marjorie Taylor green Matt
Gates
um uh various other people within the
Republican Party who took loans and you
know
look PPP loan you're talking about I'm
talking about people not only did they
tell them they got millions of dollars
relieved and look all you had to do was
I think it was uh what 90 I forgot what
the what the percentage was or how much
had to go to payroll and as soon as you
as soon as you check that one off the
box they're like great you have to pay
it back which if we're going to talk
about lazy people right you've got
someone who borrows hundreds of
thousands if not millions of dollars
during a period of time when no one can
really work because there's a [ __ ]
Health crisis going on and they don't
want to do their part and then when it
comes to paying it back they go well I
paid these employees I did this maybe
they didn't or maybe they did I don't
know I'm sure that some of these
Republicans found a lazy way to
jump through some loopholes where they
didn't actually have to do what they
needed to do right
these people will find that the cheat
codes
to the system and I'm not saying
Democrats don't do it right I would love
to abolish any sort of insider trading
or any sort of stock ownership if you're
a city member or you have family members
what have you I don't think that people
who are in politics should have that
advantage on both sides Republicans and
Democrats I think it is unfair and is a
not true representation of what we
brought them into office for so for
anyone who wants to complain about that
[ __ ] I just want to call both sides all
right both sides here shouldn't should
not be a thing
but Republicans are the ones who want to
[ __ ] and moan about ten thousand
dollars
ten thousand dollars but happily take
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
dollars and then got it written off
within a year well for people who they
are well wait now wait they're they're
entitled okay they're entitled they're
the listen they're entitled they're the
ones who should get this stuff um fake
Gabe is saying something here I'm not
sure exactly what he's saying here he
says look at these Talking Heads I think
he's talking about us
um you come here every day and and look
at us Gabe so uh fake Gabe so that's
great he says compare a contract to a
mandated shutdown of businesses I'm not
sure what the [ __ ] he's talking about
did we talk about did we talk about what
I never mentioned a contract oh what I
get what he's saying he's saying the PPP
loans were money because of mandated
shutdowns so here's here's the thing so
fake what fake Gabe is saying is that
the mandated shutdowns is the reason why
Marjorie Taylor green and these
Republicans received the PPP loans and
they got forgiveness of those bbp loans
but what he's failing to mention is the
contract
um that is the PPP loan because that's a
contract buddy that's a [ __ ] loan
it's a loan from A bank the PPP loans
were not [ __ ] loans from the
government the government subsidized
that money but the banks made a ton of
cash a ton of cash when they were giving
out those [ __ ] loans also you have to
remember that the people who are able to
get loans early were those people who
had an inside how would they know that
game I don't know the other thing too
the other thing too about this what he's
saying is
fake game you dumb [ __ ] the
student debt is a [ __ ] mandated loan
once you sign the dotted line buddy when
you're 18 you're dumb you're stupid and
you sign the dotted line for a lifetime
of debt you are coupled to that debt
even in bankruptcy they will not take
that [ __ ] debt away from you you dumb
[ __ ] it is a mandated mandated
if you want to use the word it's a
mandated debt once you take it once you
take it it's mandated the PPP loans as
much as it was for business or shutdowns
of businesses and it's mandated
talk about the Mandate my friend so easy
easy easy on the easy on the whole easy
on the whole comparing PPP loans to
[ __ ] student debt right as if it's
not comparable because they live in the
same universe it's federal subsidized
money that the federal government us we
the people gave those [ __ ] and
the people who took the PPP loans got
relief and these people who took the
student loans the subsidized student
loans are not getting the relief because
only only because of Republicans
bringing cases against it that's your
that's your gaze and that doesn't even
go into the whole predatory lending
aspect too wow right I mean that's a
whole that's a whole nother show that we
could do yeah it's a whole nother show
but the point of this that the news this
morning is that the fifth circuit which
I believe it's uh Louisiana Texas part
of Oklahoma I don't know exactly where
the fifth circuit is but but it's down
in Texas Louisiana
um the fifth circuit has has stopped the
student debt now likely the Supreme
Court is going to be the last stop here
right and they have already they have
already shot down a lot of these
um Republican attempts of taking away
the student debt relief even Amy Coney
Barrett of all [ __ ] justices
basically said no you can't stop you
can't stop the prison United I mean
there's a part of me there's a part of
me that's like [ __ ] it you know like
just if if Biden wants to play
play fair
you know like a republican he would be
like all right cool like we're just
gonna forgive everyone's loan
and uh and then be like all right cool
Republicans you can figure this [ __ ] out
we'll go to court and we'll have to deal
with all this stuff and that is
something that I would be like that is
the same tactic that Trump had during
his time right they did all these things
and Democrats had to figure out right it
was the most important one to fight in
court that fake Gabe here is pointing
out that there is a Democrat
representative that took PPP loans oh my
God they Gabe what would we ever do if a
Democrat took [ __ ] you're not
listening dummy I don't give a [ __ ] what
Representatives took it I don't care if
you're a republican if you're a Democrat
if you vote if you don't vote who took
student loan debt the president doesn't
care either he's not saying only
Democrats get student debt relief that's
not what he's saying you dumb
[ __ ] and realistically the
people who are going to benefit the
[ __ ] most from this are people in
rural areas because 10 grand 10 grand of
debt relief equals a hell of a lot more
in rural areas where the cost of living
is much lower than the blue the blue
cities their fate gave you dumb son of a
[ __ ] actually every time you do this
fake game just said something or maybe
he's not sure but I actually kind of
agree with him on something right here
what do you think rules for thee and not
for me exactly you're getting it so what
we've said this whole time there we go
this whole time is that Republicans want
to [ __ ] and moan about student loans
being forgiven
but they themselves if they're getting
money [ __ ] yeah they'll take it they'll
get it forgiven whatever they want so
exactly you are correct they finally
sinking in is it finally sinking in with
these [ __ ] idiots okay well let's I I
could spend all day on this fifth
circuit
um Court decision
that is like I I know the Administration
has already asked the Supreme Court to
rule on this ultimately and that that's
where it's going to lie it's a Supreme
Court decision
um and I'm I'm confident that the
Supreme Court's gonna say yeah you can't
stop the Executive Branch from uh at
cutting debt from that that the federal
government subsidized just the same way
that they gave relief for the PPP loans
they can give relief for the student
debt it is a thing it's there's pla oh
here we got owned apparently oh my God
we got owned we got owned the game I
don't know if we've changed anything
we've said and it literally said
do essentially here I'll I'll sum
everything up in a little it'll bow here
don't [ __ ] complain about something
that only you want and not others to get
okay and that's what Republicans are
doing they're bitching and moaning and
complaining and whining all this
[ __ ] about how
people are getting student loans
forgiven because God forbid someone gets
ten thousand dollars out of that'll
probably just pay off the [ __ ]
interest right oh my God how awful
um I gotta show you okay a Prager
University this is fantastic I got
another video I want they're obsessed
top tier they're upstairs University
right there they're obsessed they're
obsessed with other people's genitalia
so much so that they think liberals only
want trans women to dress sexy which is
weird we're going to talk about that I
also want to show you a video of this
[ __ ] Herschel Walker voter oh my God
you can't you I'm gonna show you is it
is it wait wait is it the one with the
guy who says yes I'm yep okay you know
that's not a real voter right what okay
we'll watch it yeah yeah we'll watch it
we'll watch it we'll watch it everyone
everyone um we're gonna go the [ __ ] list
Roundup because we gotta round up the
Tweety tweets and Trinity Trends because
I know I know Gabe wants to talk about
the the Elon death chip so let's let's
get to the [ __ ] let's round to start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show I think
we have some breaking news here Gabe
um as we're going to the [ __ ] list I
don't know if you're if you see my
message there looks like um is it
possible that Joel Greenberg it looks
like um let's check it out yeah go go
see what you can find on Joel Greenberg
it looks like
if you guys if the audience doesn't
remember Joel Greenberg is the uh Matt
gatz it looks like 32 minutes ago sorry
an hour ago an hour ago uh it was
sentenced to 11 years 11 years for sex
trafficking a minor in other charges
he's the he's the Ben he's the venmo
um yeah he's the venmo parts with
breaking news Joel Greenberg a tax
collector who cooperated with sex
trafficking investigation into Matt
Gates was sentenced to 11 years in
prison for crimes including trafficking
a teenage girl and stealing 400
000 in taxpayer money because remember
remember he was a tax collector in
Florida this is the guy that was
carrying around a gun because he's a tax
collector let me ask him
is he is he a Republican or a Democrat I
just want to make sure here oh Greenberg
oh oh yeah he's definitely a republican
oh that's right okay he's a republican
seminal County Tax Collector
so what you're saying is is
he stole tax money and he was trapped he
was trafficking minors it wasn't just
that it was he trafficked a teenager
yeah stalked a political rival stole
identities when taxpayer funds on paid
sex and crypto among other misdeeds 11
years yeah fake Gabe where your boy at
oh oh man them demon Democrats right oh
my God they're they're weird I I it
every time it is a weird projection I
wish I had a [ __ ] time and fake games
can be like oh you know he's gonna
fake game if you were to go back in the
chat I'm sure if they gave it said
something about Joel Greenberg and Matt
Gates oh it's not criminal it's not this
it's not [ __ ] right just like he's
like it's not criminal against Trump
every single time we talk about somebody
getting them sells [ __ ] owned by the
courts because they did something crazy
or they did something illegal fake game
wants to fight and be like that's not
what they said and it's like I've got a
link I got a link I got a link they
dropped it in the Q Anon Facebook group
um speaking of weirdos Republican
weirdos does this guy look familiar to
you
this is Dennis Prager
yeah
um Dennis Prager
he's got to be like the he's whiter than
Mitch McConnell right and he's got more
of the the the turkey neck the gobble
gobble the beard
uh turkey beard it's he is he is so
[ __ ] white and pasty like if a
Saltine cracker was a human it would be
Dennis Prager I think that's right I
called him a cracker
and breaking news someone get that
trending okay in his Prager here he he's
the founder of Prager University
um it's about in the same level
as a university As Trump University was
um or Liberty University is yeah but
Dennis Prager here has an opinion about
women dressing sexy now whenever a
republican like this talks about anyone
about sexuality in any shape or form
it gets weird fast we've watched several
videos in the last few weeks of Matt
Walsh talking about the sex and
sexuality and it gets weird really
[ __ ] fast and it it doesn't
disappoint here so I just want everyone
to know that this is Dennis Prager
here's Dennis prager's
view of what liberals think about women
dressing sexy it's weird
we have this wonderful
young woman
on Tucker Carlson last night
she went to Mount Holyoke
fifty thousand a year
all all girls school I learned something
that I did not know I wonder if you knew
I'm looking at my producer
that they had the girls get a special
haircut
okay it's really boring I mean I'm not
gonna lie it's boring as [ __ ] but it
takes a real quick turn here when he's
talking about the girl's haircut and
what they dress as listen to this you
aware of that she mentioned that and
it's the second time I've heard that
because long hair
is sort of too feminine oh my God and
you don't you don't want that I I want
to discuss that with her I think that's
a very very big deal
the idea that a girl should want to look
attractive God forbid even somewhat sexy
uh the left finds this a truly vile
the only people
the only women they want to dress sexily
are trans women
okay stop it really we quick quick quick
pause okay anyone who's like they want
to address sex like
really show sorry really shows me that
Prager here doesn't know how to um I
don't know pleasure a woman or he
doesn't I don't even know if this man
has had sex before I mean he thinks this
shirt and tie is is dressing sexily he's
like he's like whoa whoa ladies hold off
look at my haircut my sexy haircut like
this is the [ __ ] cringiest thing I've
ever seen it's weird and he 100 believes
that he is in the right and he's totally
I wouldn't be surprised if he was like
I'm an alpha male
[ __ ] gets me on this one though that
makes me go what in the [ __ ] he takes a
total I mean really honestly you know
you can sit there and have the belief
that liberals don't want women to have
long hair and don't want them to be sexy
it's really stupid [ __ ] like they also
accuse us of [ __ ] porn and all this
naked women having sex by by contrast if
right if the left doesn't want girls to
be sexy it's fun then the right says
they should be sexy right well I mean
it's all projection because this guy but
but the thing is is he goes straight to
the Matt Walsh Tucker Carlson Ben
Shapiro Nick Fuentes I don't want to
pick up a girl in a bar take her home
and she's got a wiener like they go
straight to that like how do you leap
from haircuts
to to dicks like they literally can't
stop thinking about [ __ ] penis what
in the [ __ ] like you know what you know
what I just thought what a [ __ ] weird
man maybe their fascination with younger
women right girls because Matt Walsh and
a lot of these uh my own Annapolis and
and some of these others talking about
young people
so part of me I I just kind of just
dawned on me yeah all right you've got
these Republicans who want to complain
about conversion therapy and this and
that and how somebody who might have
their own choice of their body God
forbid decided hey I don't feel
comfortable and this is not who I really
am so I wanna have certain elective
surgeries that would uh help me feel
more comfortable right because again my
body my choice
and they want to say oh you know what
you're not old enough to have those you
can't make those decisions if anything
we should ban them for good
and part of me wonders
if let's say a woman born a woman right
and they say I don't feel like a woman I
feel like more like a man yeah and I
want to you know do the process of of
sure changing myself into what I feel
comfortable right what I feel natural as
and again God forbid their body their
choice but it almost feels yeah like the
Republican party wants to stop anyone
from doing these they want to catch them
early catch them young before they could
ever do anything that would change them
um
so they go okay great I'm gonna get that
little girl and she's 10 years old and
she can't change and do this and does
that I'm gonna I'm gonna trap her I'm
gonna trap her well that's what Matt
Walsh said on his show that you gotta
get him pregnant young that way they
stay married to you forever so you think
about it he's like oh 15 16 that is
prime they are just juicy like the idea
that that is
Walsh 100 believes that is what how you
would that's what he said he said it and
he completely believes that people
they're like oh 15 16 that is when
they're their most like uh uh
perfect time their their their fertile
right and it's talking about talking
about a a young teenager a young woman a
girl like that
and so it kind of makes me think that
Republicans almost want to trap these
younger women in this idea because one
they couldn't get an older woman who's
like oh [ __ ] I'm independent I don't
want to I don't want to deal with that
but also two they're like oh if I get
them early then they won't ever
go about
um I want to point something out I know
I don't know if the algorithm's
listening to this but the and before the
uh before the uh our great moderators
act this account but but they all of a
sudden hot girl picks for you pops up on
the uh in the chat I guess I guess the
algorithm we're sitting here we're
sitting here talking about hot girls and
it's just amazing to me that these weird
sumbitches like Prager and Matt Walsh
Ben Shapiro Tucker Carlson Nick Fuentes
is telling other [ __ ] what you
should be doing about sex and sexuality
and how you're gonna dress and who's
gonna dress what it's weird [ __ ] it's
almost as weird almost as weird as these
[ __ ] who thought they were
Magneto because there was a computer
chip inside the vaccine now wanting to
make sure they get the Eight dollar
brain chip do you think he's gonna sell
it for eight bucks what do you think you
think I don't know I mean I don't know
how much this is going to cost how much
is this gonna cost
well I don't think the government's
going to subsidize this as much as far
as I know I what so so you're saying
it's not gonna it's not gonna happen
because he he needs he needs welfare to
make sure he gets his business I mean
here's the thing he might have some sort
of subsidy on the research side okay so
he he's working with UC what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is this brain chip
supposed to do
I I'm supposed to basically give people
who are paraplegic or quadripally
correction again so so the idea I mean
it's got It's got many more possibility
like the uh the potential of this to be
good is is very great exponential but
the risk it is very bad but the but the
whole Narrative of these people for the
last two years has been the Democrats
trying to control you putting a chip in
you and then they're like where do I
line up for the Eight dollar Elon brain
ship it's really [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
right I I come across the video
yesterday I don't know who this guy is I
have no clue
um Matt uh boo shell it looks like this
is on Instagram I believe
um someone pulled it put it on um on
Twitter it's fantastic it described I
never thought about Elon Musk in this
manner and if anyone is the uh fans of
the office out there you're gonna
understand exactly you're gonna go holy
[ __ ] that is right well listen to this
this is this is this is great the worst
part about Elon Musk is that we just
have to hear about him for the rest of
our lives and every idea he comes up
with is like so damn stupid like if I
had billions of dollars the last thing I
would do is be like what if I owned the
website where everyone is terrible all
the time but that's that's how his mind
works this is like our new genius and
until we die we'll keep hearing about
like he'll be like I've invented super
corn it's it's rows and rows of planted
corn it's like yeah dude that's a farm
like he just keeps coming up with old
ideas I think I think his fans are like
oh this guy's like a cool Don Draper
type but I think the rest of the world
is like no that dude is Michael Scott
the word I never I'm
I was watching I think it was an outtake
uh from the first season Oh I thought
you meant like outtakes of his remember
remember the stay woke video where he's
like in the T-shirt closet that's a
Michael Scott thing man 100 that totally
was an episode from the office somewhere
I mean I can only imagine that Elon Musk
is definitely going that's what she said
throughout the office 100 100 is saying
that's what she said whenever he can't
help it like yeah he just can't help it
but I I was watching I think it was a
deleted scene yeah from the first season
but it's been so long but I saw a clip
the other day
and it was it was everyone was in the
the like conference room and they're
having this meeting and uh there's a guy
that's in and he's presenting to be like
hey so like what are some lessons some
like values that you should have in the
office and Michael goes he's like I I
like to go and they're like okay great
yeah go go
and he goes through this list and I
forget all the names right and he's like
boom boom boom boom boom and he says all
of them and
and Pam
stops and says wait that spells incest
and then Michael Scott goes well yeah I
mean it's easy to remember but also and
then he goes like offices are like
family incest is with your family
and he goes on this whole thing I mean
it's just one of those things like the
most ridiculous thing that explained and
then Pam's like he also could have just
spelled it insect
right instead of incest so it just
really reminds me of so much of it it is
so true now that I think about it
Michael Scott I mean Elon Musk where
he's like guys I've got this great idea
and they're like but somebody already
did that years ago yeah but we're gonna
give a little we're gonna call it super
corn right we're gonna call it but but
that's really the the thing with this
chip here right is that Elon didn't
invent this chip Elon is not doing the
science behind it's not like elon's
sitting in the in the brain chip lab
coming up with this and Engineering this
we know this you know this uh very
specifically because you have friends of
yours who work at some of his companies
that are actual
rocket scientists literal literal rocket
scientists and and
they're the ones they're the ones
actually developing this technology
they're inventing these things they're
the ones and and really
um to be fair in this Avenue
um maybe not to Elon but to the people
who work for his company like Tesla and
SpaceX which he's driving absolutely
into the ground which is a shame because
those people at those companies because
of that company have access to
subsidized money where they can advance
technology to put us in a position
where we don't have to rely on fossil
fuels right like it's not going to
happen overnight right but that's the
process but they're actually doing good
work at Tesla and SpaceX yeah and
probably uh is it neuro link is that
what this company's called neural link
neural link
um because what's what's the [ __ ] the
satellite internet isn't that starlink
yep that star does he put link just in
any [ __ ]
is that the thing I mean I don't know I
guess I mean it's it's can you imagine
what he would have called genius he goes
where is it it's in the Stars it's link
Lincoln it's Lincoln something like
neurological activity link
why is it all anyways he's like it's
cars car link Tesla was already created
so who knows if it was really something
that he created or like founded totally
totally the cars that would be burning
up and exploding
right
did you get the did you get the the new
model what and he's got weird names for
him Model A and what is this well he's
got model he's got Model S AR model
three so actually how it went because it
can't be right yeah because it's owned
by Ford right the reason he wanted to do
it because he wanted them to spell sex
so it's X it's um
the Michael Scott thing
keeps making more and more sense the
horsey on the [ __ ] plane totally
something Michael Scott would do he
would totally call any company that he
has like what's the okay just add link
to it like that would be the he would
come up with a business name right I
think there's a [ __ ] episode of The
Office where Dwight and Michael Scott
are trying to name a business I believe
because didn't he start his own paper
companies like the main yeah there was
later later in later paper link paper
yeah he left but he worked with uh with
Pam and uh
and who wasn't blinking on his name damn
it's uh uh BJ Novak his character why am
I blinking on his name right I'm the
character name yeah anyway but yeah he
starts his own company but it's just
called the Michael it's the Michael
Scott Paper Company right but it's but
he's very much the same person that
would call it
or or people would say you missed a
hundred percent of the shots you don't
take Wayne Gretzky Michael Scott
right like he would quote salmon and
just include it in that as a question
right right well again if Elon started
his own paper company it would likely be
called paper link right
there we go everyone's yeah thank you
thank you Angela yeah thank you for the
chat
um oh the other news is that Republicans
207 of them
voted against of course paid sickly of
course hey fake Gabe this is your guys
yeah they voted against explain it
against paid sick leave it really feels
like it really now this is paid sick
leave these are people who have jobs
these are not lazy people these aren't
unemployed people you have to have a job
to get this sick leave but they voted
against it um so that's another piece of
news
um oh actually somebody somebody uh uh
last in last in uh or lost in France
brought up something here I actually
wanted to bring up because Elon Musk the
EU
is potentially going to ban Twitter
because of their lack of moderation
didn't didn't we talk about this well
because they were what was happening was
and I questioned this for dmca right
um or is it dcma I don't know I think
it's happening I don't know what to say
anyways California has very strict rules
on that
um and the EU has even stricter rules
than California yeah now the rest of the
country's like hey we don't give a [ __ ]
um but the thing is is that
when Elon Musk basically fired his
moderation team and
the moderation team went away and their
AI shut down for that particular thing
they started posting full movies on
Twitter I was watching I was watching
Fast and the Furious was you really the
original yeah there was there was a guy
it was actually it was funny to watch
because it went on to Reddit and a guy
who's like two weeks ago I want to say
basically what happened was this guy
started posting to he had he he had two
minute Clips right
he cut the whole movie into two minute
clips and then post it up as a thread
and he did the first one the second one
I think he did the third one but by the
next day the first one had been taken
down
uh
the 2 Fast 2 Furious was still up and I
think Tokyo Drift was still up as well
but like Clips were getting taken down
but the AI for copyright was is yeah it
doesn't exist right now yeah it's
there's no one there is no because
that's how they made that that's how
they found a lot of the copyright
problems is they have an AI they have
right exactly and then someone and then
a moderation team would check the same
way the same way that YouTube and other
other uh platforms will scan and listen
to the audio or scan the visual
typically it's the audio that will
trigger just like when we play a video
here when we play you know sometimes I
say oh they're gonna shut this off on
YouTube yeah um because we get a
copyright thing and we gotta either take
it down or demise because it'll always
be unless you distort or manipulate the
audio that's why when you watch videos
on YouTube someone might uh they might
adjust the pain or something yeah and so
they heighten it up so it sounds a
little more High faster or lower you
know faster or they might reverse the
image so when you look at it it's
completely reverse it's because they're
trying to uh get around the AI the AI
but but I told you at that moment when
they were posting the full videos I'm
like dude the EU is going to eat their
lunches oh yeah I was like he's gonna
get his his lunch ate on this there's
gonna be class action lawsuits just in
copyrights alone right like this guy's
probably gonna spend hundreds of
millions if not billions of dollars in
[ __ ] class action lawsuits not just
with the employees but because he won't
moderate content right
people own this [ __ ] I said to you in
our in our chat I was like I wouldn't be
surprised if Elon Musk is the reason
that there's like new [ __ ] laws and
restrictions put on dmca
in terms of how to handle those
copyrights like how to handle that
content because now it's just like up in
the air and they're like oh we got to
fix this and fix that but there's no
team there's no moderation team there's
no child I mean half the child
exploitation team right on there I saw
people try to defend I made a post about
it where I was like oh Elon says number
one priority and then immediately cuts a
team to be less than half and I saw
people that are like well clearly they
weren't doing their job you think the
answer is to cut half of the team and
not replace them yeah but it's not even
yeah but it's not even I mean he is
cutting employees but he's turning off
AI because he can't he can't manage to
keep this stuff you know ethics the
ethics AI team they're like boom you're
done you're gone the human rights team
do you're done like people are like oh
yeah we don't need those things are you
[ __ ] serious well and that's why the
EU that's why that's why the EU is is
warning him right right it's it's not
it's not because of these dmca but it's
it's it's the actual hate speech the
misinformation like uh like lost in
France is saying here now it's because
you're not moderating I don't know Nazis
I mean that's literally what's what's
happening but the main I think the main
was uh they were they really kind of
were pissed off about the covid-19
misinformation that was the big one
because they were saying
yeah you have to if you have to monitor
this stuff because if you don't it's
going to run rampant and it's going to
be bad because it starts with covid-19
and it'll leak into other stuff did he
brag about that do I am I remembering
that right
um bragged about hey we turned the
covid-19 misinformation he might have
commented on somebody's post about that
and then I don't know Elon is is
literally beating these conspiracies and
these ideas that good things don't work
right or or questioning them you know
and he's like uh there seems to be some
truth in this just like he was like oh
hey here's this conspiracy about Paul
Pelosi being gay and the lover coming
and smashing his head with the hammer
that that's not what happened and also
the fact that he just like deleted it
just like other things he'll just like
delete it
oh nobody saw me except 119 million
people follow you someone is bound to
see it wow 119 is what it says I right I
mean and then we ran the numbers on it
like 60 of them yeah it's like 70 but
the funniest part is yesterday he goes
hey we're doing a purge of all of these
Bots and controls and stuff right yeah
okay and he's like so expect your
follower count to go down and then I
come and I was like but not elon's
because literally elon's keeps going up
right so I can tell you for a fact that
his his numbers are not going to go down
no well I mean he's not gonna he's not
gonna get rid of bots that follow his
account though it is predicted it is
predicted uh I forget how long the
period is but supposedly because I think
Obama has the most amount of Twitter
followers let me just check this really
quick hold on so he he Obama's number
one right Obama's got 133.2 and I
believe he has the most of anyone on
Twitter and think that's right either
that or Bieber right Bieber's up there
too uh
114 113.6 so I think Obama has the most
with 133.2 you know that you've got to
get in Trump's crawl right oh yeah 100
and so you when I was reading about it
they were saying that I forgot what the
time period was but they were expecting
at a certain certain point within the
next year they were saying if everything
goes as it has been Elon Musk will be
the most followed person on Twitter
which is hilarious because it's it is
one of those like I'm taking my ball and
I'm going home things
if I can't be the most followed person
in the world
even though all these people are [ __ ]
Bots he paid 44 billion just to be the
most followed person that is crazy well
he also paid 44 billion to run to run
polls on Twitter and be the uh the
dictator and that's why that's why
um the former head of of trust and
safety was like I don't feel like
Twitter is safe under this guy when it
when it literally was like when it falls
into a situation that feels like a
dictator is just individually choosing
these rules going forward then I can't
be here anymore and that's why he quit
well speaking of Elections and polls
um oh God this is this is uh on CNN and
you see the guy here right here that guy
is the uh lieutenant governor of Georgia
currently he he is he is a republican
okay
and he's going to talk about in this
clip
who he voted for speaking of polls and
voting
it's not a very long clip because it
doesn't take long for him to talk about
who he who he voted for let's listen to
who the lieutenant governor he's a
republican of Georgia voted for I showed
up to vote this morning I was one of
those folks who's got in line and spent
about an hour waiting and uh you know it
was the most disappointing ballot I've
ever stared at my entire life since I
started voting you know I had two
candidates that I just couldn't couldn't
find anything that that made sense for
me to put my my vote behind it so I
walked out of that that Ballot Box uh
showing up to vote but not voting for
either one of them [ __ ] didn't
line for an hour [ __ ] stood and
this is true he stood in line for an
hour do you think he really stood in
line and didn't vote or do you think he
didn't vote at all voted for Warnock
yeah and I I have a feeling that yeah he
was like I'd rather have somebody with a
brain than without a brain well even if
it's just a big buck you right like a
big [ __ ] you to to Herschel Walker and
Donald Trump because the the governor of
Georgia energetic governor and and the
Secretary of State for that matter they
[ __ ] hate Trump they [ __ ] hate
that [ __ ] because they put them
in a situation where they had to go
[ __ ] testify in front of a grand jury
about [ __ ] crimes that this guy was
trying to get him to do yeah but it just
it's hilarious
um where is I [ __ ] thought I
retweeted see here's what happens bro oh
you know what he it's because you
probably saw Aaron post it you got to go
back to Aaron's account because he had
it and then deleted it because he got
duped as well oh is that what it is it's
a funny clip because I saw it I was like
oh I should use Aaron or Ace no it's
Aaron because I was like oh I should use
this in my her my next Herschel Walker
what was that that I'm working right
well see and then I posted a link and I
put it I took from my phone to my
computer and I refreshed it and it was
like oh this doesn't exist and I was
like what the hell so I went to his
account and then he added contacts to it
pretended herschwalker voter
okay this is a different clip than what
I was looking at oh is it the guy that's
a republican that says he's not gonna
vote for Walker
yeah well no well yeah okay I see here's
what happens folks and a lot of people
are on to me about this
I retweet the sh the [ __ ] I want to show
on the show
I basically am producing the entire show
from Twitter okay it's not that Capital
it's not a gun but some people like he
retweets a lot yeah because I'm
retweeting the [ __ ] I want to show
everybody and I just don't want to lose
it it's easy just go to my [ __ ]
timeline and just find it a lot of times
I'll comment but sometimes I'm just
retweeting because I'm like I don't want
to forget this clip but this is a clip
of a comedian that you're saying this is
on CNN yeah yeah so who is this guy he's
got a I don't I don't know who the guy
is oh but but yeah I was like oh that's
a funny shirt this is real okay let's
let's watch I just like how he talks and
like the stories he tells and you know
and he just he's off the cuff he's not
all serious about everything he's not
everything's not a big deal to him you
know is he the best candidate for the
job maybe not I mean is he the most
qualified guy in the world I don't know
maybe not
but does he have a great attitude yes
the reason why you're duped by this and
and the shirt is great he said the
insurance says I'm with her Shoal right
I'm with her again I don't know who made
this shirt
but it's great if it's real if it's real
God damn it now here's we missed an
opportunity for the uh the shirt there
yeah here's what I'll tell you
the reason why you get duped by [ __ ]
like this is because literally you go to
Trump rally they're saying [ __ ] like
this this is the exact same [ __ ] they're
saying and we've said this over and over
time and time again these people are so
[ __ ] hard to parody and do satire
it's it's difficult and I remember dude
then it becomes then right well last
year they were drinking piss they were
drinking their own piss for covet you
remember this Gabe text me he's like hey
I'm gonna do a drinking piss video I'm
like nope you can't do drinking piss you
gotta go to level 100. you gotta eat
your [ __ ] and you did the video you even
made a fake turd didn't you yeah I made
a fake turret right and ate the and at
some point they were eating dirt and
turds yeah I think the magic dirt right
I was like God damn it they just they
just never did oh here's the this is it
this is the one yeah that's the one I
thought you were talking about that's
this is the one yeah this is the one now
this um well here uh let me here's the
guy right uh in this clip and it's on
MSNBC okay and they're interviewing him
as a as a voter that's leaving the polls
and they're asking he's a republican
right listen to what he says about
Warnock it's uh it's you just listen I
voted for Herschel I'm a republican I
own my own business that's how I evolved
it that way did you vote for Herschel in
the general election too yes he's gonna
have to make up some ground in order to
pull off oh he's going to lose in all
probability Mr Warnock is a wonderful
individual
uh okay Gabe the reason why he voted for
Herschel her Shoal
um
because he's with her Shoal is because
he's a Republican and he owns a business
somehow this
I don't know what this means
why he thinks her show will be better
for him
but these are real people
this is a real thing this is not a
comedian that is like hey
sure he doesn't have a platform sure
every time he does a public speech he
talks about vampires or dogs or walls or
his son having an alien baby body or
whatever it might be but okay he's a
republican so what the hell did you just
say about an alien what there's a clip
from 2019 of Herschel Walker giving a
speech where he I've used not that clip
but I've used a part of the clip in the
first person oh yeah okay okay
uh what was this is where he's talking
to like the military where he has the
Cassius Clay shirt I've seen these clips
before and I I've watched a few of them
and I just don't want to give that
amount of my life away yeah don't worry
I'll I'm gonna snip him into little bits
little chunks I mean look I had to I'll
tell you right now I had to I tried to
hire a Linguistics translator
and I I tried to hire a Linguistics
translator and give them all these
speeches of Herschel Walker and you know
what they did what they immediately
refunded me the money and they said we
can't do this I'm sorry good luck they
were like we can't we can't we can't
decode anything he's saying right now
here's your money right back we'll
actually pay you if you could figure it
out so now I'm decoding my own [ __ ]
[ __ ] well speaking of uh weird [ __ ] he
says here is here is her show Walker
um talking about Herschel
talking about how his race is gonna
control the Senate I guess on Newsmax of
all places let's
let's give away this 40 seconds of Our
Lives it is very very important this
election here is about uh you know about
controlling the senate in the sense that
you know we're not going to let them
take the Senate away right now we can
have uh everyone have the different
committers now the committee could be
even whereas if if uh the Republican
lose that senate seat then the Democrat
got total control right now we got a
chance to make all the Committees even
that that we can still do some
correction on it and and that's what I'm
going to fight for him okay he's
actually right here he's actually saying
the right thing the first part where
he's like it's for the control of the
Senate that's completely wrong but what
he's saying here about the control of
the Committees that's absolutely correct
they are if if Warnock wins the
Democrats are not going to have to do an
agreement with Mitch McConnell for
shared power inside the Committees
they're not gonna have to do that
they're gonna have full [ __ ] subpoena
power they're gonna have full
chairmanships it's going to be full on
Democrat committees in the Senate so he
is correct here more reason to go vote
against this dumb [ __ ] like he's
giving us he's giving you the reason
folks to go vote against him he's giving
you the reason now again he's saying
that that the control of the senate in
the first part and then he kind of
corrects himself I don't know if he got
on yeah man this guy is completely
saying I I keep seeing okay I do want to
acknowledge uh we do need to talk about
a recent alleged yeah alleged love
affair
to with who
uh with my best friend
no you're talking about Alex Stein and
Marjorie Taylor green oh my God I feel
like we owe it to the audience do you
think us this do you think because this
is the new hot juicy gas do you think
that they had six
dude part of me is like I mean you don't
want to think about it but at the same
time I don't want to think about it but
he was on her show no he was on more
than just her show
but if I had to guess whoa uh there's a
part of me that's like yeah maybe it's
like the the the the conservative right
Republican trumpism either eating each
other kind of thing which is even funny
wait you're getting okay okay
no Chewie munchie no
um no
um God damn it okay what I mean to say
yeah
maybe they did maybe they didn't but I'd
like to think that they did because I
would like to imagine that look if
there's smoke there's fire and we
already know that Margaret Taylor green
loves to [ __ ] ride that
man you you you really are getting and
yeah go ahead she just she gets on that
horse she gets on that horse you know
she straps in puts the feet into [ __ ]
straps whoa whoa is did Alex Stein get
pegged is that what you're saying oh no
she's putting out the straps she likes
to write I'm just asking questions okay
I mean you know it's it's uh viable you
should ask questions what I'm saying is
that supposedly allegedly allegedly
allegedly allegedly but probably
allegedly for sure but it definitely
sex with Marty Taylor green now the idea
do you think do you think he had to
massage your toes I'm just wondering
this is all I we're gonna lose our
audience here talking about this they're
dropping off like they're dropping over
here I don't know exactly I don't want I
don't want to think about those details
right okay I'm sure they did something
[ __ ] gross and nasty whatever because
that's just who they are 100 100 I think
their sex life is reflective of how they
actually live their normal he held the
camera because he always he's always oh
you know I probably he probably did did
he use a selfie stick
you think I know I think he's got a
camera does he just hold it so he's just
holding the phone
yeah yeah yeah yeah so you think they he
didn't set up a tripod maybe he put a
GoPro on he just [ __ ] went that might
be it that might but look Alan the idea
that Alex Stein yeah probably uh hooked
up or slept with Margie Taylor green I
think is hilarious and I think it's
totally on brand all right like I
wouldn't be surprised if Matt Gates also
went into the marjor Taylor green Arena
as well as the polyamory isn't she a
little old man though I mean oh yeah
well I mean dude she doesn't CrossFit I
wouldn't be surprised if she got a good
hold on him and just whoa so you're
saying like she you know I mean that day
that they went to the beach where where
uh Walter or Walter owned them part of
me is like oh man they were driving
around all day who knows what they did
in the back seat you know who knows and
check who could tell really with these
folks for anyone who doesn't know who
Alex Stein is he's the [ __ ] that was
sexually harassing AOC on the capitol
steps he's serial sexual harassment
I made a video about him he got very
upset he did
sorry and then he and then he blocked me
and then he started reporting my video
because it contained sensitive content
right right which I think is ironic he
knows who we are because he went on a
podcast and talked about us yeah yeah
um on the podcast and he and he's always
he's always on these other [ __ ]
right-wing shows that [ __ ] hate my
guts right and hate your guts they
[ __ ] hate us right it's and it's the
same [ __ ] troll same group that calls
me when they were talking about like
they're the same group that they're like
oh Gabe's eyebrows and I'm like Ah
that's just how they are man oh yeah
that was the metro station they might
get a little long here and I might trim
it but that's it you know just a little
bit you know right well you got to trim
it up you can't have stray hairs you
know sticking out I gotta trim the hair
on my [ __ ] ears so that's luckily I
don't do that yeah well you know and
what maybe one of these days somebody
where's the video we gotta watch it what
video of them having sex no oh I was
like whoa there's a video what the I'm I
mean I might be interested of this news
hitting the streams
oh
what
there's a there's a clip yes oh the one
from [ __ ] uh Baked Alaska
oh yeah I this guy this is the
insurrectionist right yeah yeah
okay so we'll play this and then I got
another I've got another
um speaking of insurrectionist I got
another
um Trump supporter I want to show you
and this guy's a right winger and he is
truly excited that um
Nick Fuentes the Nazi
um went and and it's and I think oh oh
sorry they were asking the video that I
did oh yeah okay okay
uh I'll put it I'll put it in the chat
I'll put it in the chat there you go
yeah yeah yeah all right so what was
that yeah yeah yeah
uh let's see let me go to this right
wing watch post of this video
of this Nazi really excited the Nazi
went in
um
visited with Donald Trump this guy this
guy's name is
Vincent James I think we played a few
clips of this one yeah yeah this guy
yeah [ __ ] this guy yeah this guy's weird
so let's let's go to uh let me see let
me go to this video first
um this is him talking about
um the hubbub of Nazis eating dinner
with the head knots eat Donald Trump
here is here's let me turn it up a bit
here so we can hear it here's here's
this guy talking about Jonathan Swann's
post on Twitter about the dinner with
Kanye Milo and the Nazi Nick Fuentes new
statement from former president Trump in
response to our story about his dinner
with yay and Fuentes Kanye West very
much wanted to visit Mar-A-Lago our
dinner meeting was intended to be Kanye
and only me but he arrived with the
guest whom I've never met and knew
nothing about
okay well still not a a disavowel which
is certainly good uh still refuse so
there he's saying that Trump didn't
disavow Nick Fuentes which is a good
thing to this person right which
honestly I'm not saying it's a bad thing
either it just shows you who they really
are I mean that's the true nature of
this is that this guy Nick Fuentes
Donald Trump Milo Kanye they're really
showing you who they are speaking
speaking of Kanye yeah uh Kalyn just
sent me uh I guess Kanye had another
breakdown Christ because he's on Alex
Jones today oh really so he's really
making the um the circuit you know
because you got to remember when I was
telling you guys yesterday the reason
that Kanye was connected with Milo is
because Alex Jones's team reached out to
Kanye and said hey Milo wants to connect
and wants to chat and then the reason
that out Nick Fuentes came in is because
Milo introduced Nick and Kanye so
they're all connected in this [ __ ]
pool and Marjorie Taylor green is in
connection here too because Marjorie
Taylor green we know Milo but if I
remember correctly she spoke out against
Nick Fuentes so like you've got these
people who are going well and it's it
it's you know the person who went and
spoke to the America first
um Nazi rally because there was a bunch
of young white Nazis there that's
literally kind of how she framed it up
to disavow Nick Fuentes now in this
moment it it seems like the same thing
where she's supporting Kevin McCarthy to
be quite honest but I'll get to this uh
TMZ clip yeah yeah
um of the uh Infowars but let's let's
listen to Vincent James here describe
Nick Winters and why it's important that
Donald Trump doesn't disavow like
murderers either green did using at this
point right now that we're recording
this refusing to disavow Nick this is
according to the guardian Donald Trump
shied away from criticizing Nick Fuentes
the former U.S president was urged
publicly and privately to announce
Fuentes in the aftermath aftermath of
the dinner but Trump issued making
outright this vowels of Fuentes the
people said
despite his efforts from advisors who
reached Trump over Thanksgiving holiday
Trump ultimately made clear that he
fundamentally did not want to criticize
Fuentes hmm
can you imagine
can you imagine if they keep this like
close to their vest all of a sudden
Trump gets right Trump wins gets elected
all of a sudden we find out Nick Fuentes
is the new
um Stephen Miller like Nick Fuentes is
the new advisor and
okay if you don't need
another reason to make sure to stay
engaged in your democracy from now until
the end of time other than that the Nick
Fuentes would be the next Stephen Miller
yeah think about that for a second but
Vincent James also then pushes into the
idea yeah yeah he said I would also be
in right which is like Jesus right
you're right well this this is uh
ultimately just as bad or worse of a
clip
um I think this is after he start this
talk
um let's listen to this one here we have
in fact infiltrated the
mainstream flank of the GOP just look at
what Tucker Carlson is talking about
lately these things just sort of happen
on their own now of course if we had a
platform if we were able to speak freely
if we were allowed on YouTube still and
allowed on these platforms still then
these things would have happened a lot
quicker but you can see which way the
wind is blowing the way that taco
Carlson is talking right now is because
the wind is blowing that direction the
way that Charlie Kirk is talking on
Twitter the way that the way that Matt
Walsh is talking on Twitter
is because they see which way the wind
is blowing now whether they're authentic
or not in their views I would argue that
some of them certainly aren't
um and they just see which way the wind
is blowing there are some that are and
this is what the converse Tucker Carlson
is talking about the 1965 hard seller
immigration and nationality act and
talking about what Ted Kennedy promised
during this act and saying that it
completely transformed the nation and
talking about demographic change like
this is something these are things that
you never thought you would see on Fox
News you have people taking over school
boards and you have
uh what is it one-third of the people
that got elected into House of
Representatives were all like election
they denied the results of the 2020
election
um people taking over school boards and
talking about the degeneracy that is
being pushed in schools we have the
nation parts of the nation talking about
secession
talking about banning gay marriage and
banning contraceptives and
we have in fact our beliefs have in fact
infiltrated the mainstream flank of GOP
politics
because people are beginning to see
that our views our worldview our beliefs
are the inevitable conclusion or need to
be rather the inevitable conclusion
and the necessary reaction actually to
what's happening to the country today
he's talking about white supremacy I I
hate to I hate to burst the bubble but
he's talking about white supremacy here
he's talking about
why it's so important that their white
views are pushed because of the
replacement Theory because that's that's
what he's he's saying is becoming
mainstream what's this link you sent me
here of him oh boy okay so uh uh the
link I was going to send you I sent you
from the TMZ article there's more that's
set in there but because Vincent because
we're on the topic of isn't James the
crossover between him and Kanye you have
not seen this clip so I have not seen
this clip you have not seen this clip
and neither probably has a lot of the
audience but listen to what Kanye says
and listen to how Vincent James reacts
this is from their visit on Alex Jones
today okay so this is the video of Kanye
yeah yeah on the show and it looks like
Nick Fuentes is there too and then and
then Vincent James the Nazi that we just
listened to is gonna react is that what
you're saying okay let me pull this let
me pull this clip up here
um
oh boy
you're not Hitler you're not a Nazi you
don't deserve to be called that a
demonized well
I I see I I see good things about Hitler
also I love them Jewish people are not
going to tell me [ __ ] you can oh my God
you know us and you can love what we're
doing to you with the contracts and you
can love what we're you know what we're
pushing with the pornography but this
guy that invented highways invented the
very microphone that I use as a musician
you can't say out loud that this person
ever did anything good and I'm done with
that I'm done with the classifications
every human being has something of value
that they brought to the table so true
especially
no no no no no no is there more play it
the Hitler you're not hit to the table
so true especially Hitler let's play it
again let's play it again
every human being has something of value
that they brought to the table so true
especially Hitler you
know oh damn okay I want to play it one
more time because I just don't want
anyone to get confused about what he's
saying here yeah listen up listen one
more time
and I'm done with that I'm done with the
classifications every human being has
something of value that they brought to
the table so true especially Hitler
whoosh are you are you now uh Kanye has
been accused
um just in the last few weeks at his
company that he would say in meetings he
would talk about Hitler and how people
you know should holy [ __ ]
so here is Alex Jones trying to serve
Kanye softball by saying you're not
Hitler people are accusing you being
Hitler people are kissing you being Nazi
and he's like that's because I am
like like literally he's like yeah
that's the reason why is because I think
Hitler's cool yeah what the [ __ ] how in
the [ __ ] is this even number one why is
he wearing what what's the body suit
thing I don't know what that is it's
just the thing that he normally wears
like he has like he's he'll he'll have
full-on head masks like he's had ones
with like the jewels on them and stuff
it's just part of oh okay he's done it
in shows before too I haven't seen that
I I want the recent you know clips and
[ __ ] of him yeah I've only that I've
seen is just him like um you know on on
a podcast and you know he's got weird
[ __ ] boots on and [ __ ] but I I've
never seen him in the whole body suit it
looks it's really it's [ __ ] weird
yeah um but then
then he's saying
he said
especially
yeah like Alex Jones even was like what
not fun right what I mean
you know Baby Hitler might have been
cute right but yeah yeah at some point
Hitler's Hitler ma'am and it's not
especially no no it is not it is not
especially what this is this is look
people want to say yeah he's got mental
he's got mental problems mental issues
you know he's he's was diagnosed bipolar
but bipolar doesn't make you
anti-semitic
bipolar does that make you say oh you
know what I believe in the Holocaust and
Hitler did great things bipolar is not
an excuse for someone to be like hey you
know what I [ __ ] hate all Jewish
people right that's that's what Kanye is
saying not only does he not only is
there's no Semitic not only is he
anti-semitic now he he is saying
especially Hitler was a good person and
he did really good things like and I I I
think what he's trying to get at because
he said he invented highways which
Hitler did not invent highways it's the
same I mean it's the same as saying Elon
Musk invented electric cars like nah
it's not a thing like that's look I
under look and for anyone out there like
I understand like you know if you're
diagnosed bipolar and you have that
obviously that it can make you lose
touch with reality and you can have dis
disassociation with things but again
like the excuse that you're going to
push the idea
like if anything
those feelings are already there
being bipolar and having people
feed you more of this will only
accelerate or bolster and already
established
anti-semitic View
right it doesn't just like pop up and be
like hey I'm now anti-semitic right like
but in this clip let's watch it again
because in this clip Alex Jones is
trying to give Kanye
right an out here yeah yeah and he's
like no [ __ ] that I'm leaning full in
and I'm I'm I like Hitler and we haven't
commented on the reaction of the Nazi in
the corner the the Vincent James but
he's excited Dave listen
real true white supremacists out there
Kanye West if they took over the country
like Vincent James was saying Nick
Fuentes and him being part of a trump
Administration Kanye West be one of the
first that they wanted to rid this
country of yep okay that is just how
this [ __ ] works that's how white
supremacy works but nothing excites them
more
then a black man like Kanye asked who
has a huge [ __ ] microphone a huge
audience that he's talking to saying
[ __ ] like this right that's what they
want the most but let's let's watch it
again because it's
worth watching these are the people who
Trump dined with by the way and Alex
Jones is a person who Trump loves loves
the guy he's been on shows several times
let's watch you're
Hitler you're not a Nazi you don't
deserve to be called out and demonized
well
I I see I I see good things about Hitler
also I love everyone and Jewish people
are not going to tell me [ __ ] you can oh
my god
um you know us and you can love what
we're doing to you with the contracts
and you can love what we're you know
what we're pushing with the pornography
but this guy that
invented highways invented the very
microphone that I use as a musician you
can't say out loud that this person ever
did anything good and I'm done with that
I'm done with the classifications every
human being has something of value that
they brought to the table so true
especially Hitler
and Vincent James of course you can hear
his reaction there he's more excited
than anything to hear Kanye West say
this [ __ ] because he's he is he is a he
Vincent James like he said in the other
Clips right and is is excited right that
anti-Semitism in white supremacy have
made their way into mainstream media via
the mouth of a very well-known celebrity
artist right right the idea that this
person whatever platform will accept him
anymore
is pushing this idea that Vince and
James and other white supremacists very
much believe in and they are [ __ ]
ecstatic that they have someone now
that's pushing it and not only that but
they have someone who isn't white
pushing that out that's right that's
what excites them more oh yeah well
because they're playing they're playing
a clip in the background of American
History it's an American History X right
because the reason the reason is because
when he was on
um
uh when he went on to Tim Poole's show
on Tim the one that we showed the clip
of uh he made a mention about it being
like about him being like American
History X about him being biting the
curb and them killing him
that is is I would imagine is why they
brought this up I don't know if they
mentioned it earlier in this clip or on
the show I'd have to go back and watch
but it is something he has previously
mentioned him saying I'm the victim I
feel like I'm this guy right here
so let me ask you because I think you
know
this is all craziness
is the [ __ ] dumbest timeline this is
this is the Republican party though I
agree with Vincent James that they have
bought this narrative Hook Line Sinker
and the reason why is because they have
no other
when's the last time you heard her
[ __ ] Republican talking about
deficits or debt
they don't they don't have any ideas
they don't have any policies they're not
going to fix anything that's clear it's
going to be no no clearer than when the
Republicans take the house next year and
also they're going to be able to talk
about is Hunter Biden's laptop they're
not going to do anything for the
American people not a [ __ ] thing
they're not going to give two shits
about America and it's and the problem
is they have no ideas and the reason why
is because they bought this white
supremacy Hook Line sinker
and for Kanye West to compare the scene
from American History X where he curb
Stomps
uh that the white supremacist
who goes to prison for it curbs Thompson
kills the black man in the first scene
um of American History X to compare that
white supremacist as Jewish people and
then he it's [ __ ] weird but that's
their logic I guess my question here is
who in the [ __ ] is is is
you think Kanye's coming up with this on
his owner you think people like Nick
Fuentes Milo Candace Owens are [ __ ]
putting these ideas in his brain so this
is this is what I believe is happening I
believe Kanye who is bipolar uh I
believe he is having a manic episode now
you know you could be like oh you're not
a doctor Gabe well I'm just going to
look at just the bear kind of like uh
outside perspective it does seem like
the last time this happened he was
having an episode and I feel like he is
happening up having an episode again
now I believe he does believe this to an
extent now I don't know how much but he
definitely believes it to an extent
again being bipolar and having a manic
episode doesn't make you just all of a
sudden invent the idea of yourself being
an anti-semite I think those things are
true to what he believes
I also believe that having Milo Nick
Fuentes having Candace Owens really the
one that [ __ ] lit the [ __ ] flame
on this one but I think all of these
people are are taking it are are
manipulating in ways but taking
advantage of a guy who is suffering from
an episode
and I think they're taking advantage and
I think they are using it to to their
own benefit and they're pushing this
idea that everyone is after you right
because you know people who do have
other you know those who have bipolar or
are bipolar in their family I'm sure
that they know that those people who go
through an episode might be paranoid
thinking stress that everything is out
to get them right they're they're very
paranoid in that sense so I think Kanye
who again already all eyes on him lights
Paparazzi already a Target as a
celebrity in that way I think only
exacerbates this even more
and then you have a group of people who
are saying that
uh oh this is
this is what is this is what's happening
right it's the Jewish people coming
after humans this and this and all these
execs I mean I saw a video the other day
where he pulled up a chart and it was
all of these like top execs from the top
whatever Fortune 500 companies and he
was like every one of these labeled in
red are Jewish people right
and the fact that he's got that ready to
go to like debunk anyone who says these
things is insane it's like fake Gabriel
posting in the [ __ ] He's copying [ __ ]
from other places on Facebook and post
them in the chat here like oh look a
definition of fascism Biden is a
dictator or whatever the [ __ ] and um and
I I just wanna I wanna point out here
that
um yeah number one Kanye and Alex Jones
and Infowars jump to number one uh
trending on Twitter and here's the thing
we always say Don't Look Away
um and really honestly this this um
this new Twitter that we have right
um obviously Elon is driving it into the
ground
but he is putting their microphone and
them out in the open of who they really
are and what they really think and what
they want to be right out in the open
like sunlight like a [ __ ] so you
must you must make sure that it is
disinfected with this sunlight because
they're giving you all the sunlight you
need when Kanye West is going on Alex
Jones's show on Infowars and Alex Jones
is telling him hey they're calling you
Hitler and they're calling you Nazi and
you're not and he's like he literally
says the word well yeah hold my beer
it's kind of like no yeah because he
said he his response to Alex his first
word that pops in his brain when Alex
Jones is like you're not a Nazi and
you're not Hitler and he's like well
literally about Hitler right so like
what [ __ ] crazy man what in the [ __ ]
is happening it's just and now again
folks as dangerous as it might seem that
Kanye West is doing this
the great part about what we know now is
that Vincent James Nick Fuentes Milo
yiannopoulos Marjorie Taylor green the
stuff we've been saying about them for
the last [ __ ] two years on this show
it's all true all of it Matt Walsh
Tucker Carlson this Vincent James has
got a boner about Fox News talking about
replacement Theory
because he loves Hitler and he loves
when Kanye says that he loves Hitler and
he thinks he's a great person that just
shows you who the [ __ ] they are and and
that is why Carrie Lake loss that is
what Venture lost Blake Masters lost
mastriano [ __ ] lost that that's that
is why the crazies are losing because
they're [ __ ] Nazis yeah okay they're
not even even Kanye West you're not a
Nazi you're not a Nazi you're not Hitler
well I mean literally he literally waved
him and out right he offered Alex Jones
crazy conspiracy theorist guy who wants
to push everything idea and it was
[ __ ] a hoax this hoax that gave him a
[ __ ] out and said well you're not
like him like you may think some things
but you're not like Hitler you don't
believe in Hitler and he goes well
Hitler had some things of value to add
right us like and everyone should be
cared for as a human especially Hitler
it's like like why how how are we
jumping to this idea that Hitler was
someone that we should [ __ ] support
right this guy did atrocities hey Gabe
you wanna you wanna see how to spot a
Nazi you want to see this fake Gabe says
Schumer literally said they want to
replace voters you want the quote what
does that have to do well number one
here's what it has to do with here's
what face Gabe's saying a Jewish person
who is who is the leader who is the
leader of the Democrats in the Senate he
said that he they want to replace voters
just what [ __ ] Kanye West is saying
just what Tucker Carlson Vincent James
hey fake Gabe you're a Nazi you're a
Nazi you [ __ ] bonehead
get give the quote if you want but what
happens with all voters is they are
replaced when they die and a new
generation becomes old enough to vote
they're replaced the electorate changes
you [ __ ] bonehead that's what the
quote is I know you put the quote here
but that's what the quote is about
is about a generation dying off because
they're dying and a generation getting
older like voting age-wise so yeah that
vote is being replaced that's that's how
it's going to work that's how it always
that's how it's always worked
is old people die young people get old
enough to vote dummy
that's how it works that's how it
[ __ ] works you [ __ ] idiot and we
win all this before where you're like oh
they want immigrants to vote they're
getting them to vote and then you send
this link where it shows that they they
wouldn't let it happen they wouldn't
pass the law they wouldn't put the
referendum you do this [ __ ] all the time
and the reason why you post this [ __ ]
fake game is because you believe with
Vincent James you believe Kanye West
Nick Fuentes Milo yiannopoulos Marjorie
Taylor green Matt gatz Joel Greenberg
who's just been sentenced to 11 years
you believe Donald Trump you believe all
of it all of it because you're a [ __ ]
bonehead but more than anything fake
Gabe you're uh [ __ ] Nazi this is what
Nazis say this is what the [ __ ] they say
my friend so thanks for coming here and
setting the [ __ ] thing up on the tee
just like Alex Jones set it up on the
team for Kanye West to say no no I'm not
a Nazi I'm not Hitler yeah he was like
yeah you're you're not a Nazi you're not
Hitler
well that's my best impression everyone
come back tomorrow I'm sure there'll be
some more crazy [ __ ] uh and I'm I almost
am sure I'm almost sure that yay Kanye
is gonna make it on the bonehead of the
list
I I am almost sure there's no way that
this [ __ ] trending like he's
trending for what he's trending for does
not make it to where you can vote for
him so go does not make it and does not
win right good luck your [ __ ]
be in the [ __ ] contest yeah you
[ __ ] uh you better be voting uh
so go to at Tony Michael's spot on
Twitter you can vote there on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod uh Gabe will be
putting the bonehead of the week pull up
there and then I'll throw it over on
YouTube so don't forget to subscribe to
the YouTube channel just go to the
community tab just go over scroll over
to they kind of move the community tab
over more so you guys gotta scroll if
you're on your phone you gotta scroll
over more just go to the community tab
you can vote on YouTube as well um we
don't rig votes here we everyone's vote
counts yep
um so go vote for bone end of the week
we'll we'll break it down tomorrow in
the second hour also download every
single episode
every single one of them on Apple's
modify Google make sure to leave us a
great review of why you're there and if
you wanna if you want to talk to the
Nazi fake game go
go
to our page at the Tony Michaels on
Facebook and so that stupid [ __ ] lives
um I I can't imagine why fake Gabe would
get banned from the Midas touch page and
now now I now I know like I said you
know I've done in the past I invited
fake Gabe on the show but he wants me
face to face right you know I I've
considered Banning him because of some
of the [ __ ] he says and it's probably
gonna be happen eventually because he's
just not gonna he's just gonna say some
vile stupid [ __ ] that's gonna force me
to [ __ ] ban him from Facebook that
way he'd be like oh you banned me yeah
you're saying this [ __ ] and I'm not
gonna put up with it but go while he's
still here on Facebook make sure to
follow Aunt empty Tony Michaels
um and come watch every single weekday
noon Eastern 11 Central nine Pacific as
we bash bash fake game and just the
Trump copy machine in general because
that's what fake Gabe really is to us he
just he's so great at copying pasting
nonsense well as he said suppress Free
Speech or sorry press speech fascist oh
yeah because because fake gave me
pulling up your comments on a YouTube
channel where I'm getting thousands
hundreds of thousands of views a week
and suppressing your speech you are a
stupid bastard you are such a dumb
[ __ ] everyone don't be like fake
Gabe do not be like fake Gabe go with
love go with heart make sure if you're
in Georgia you get out stand in line and
vote don't do what the lieutenant
governor did and just stand in line for
an hour not vote go vote vote vote we
need that vote we need that seat as
Herschel Walker says so we can controls
the Senate everyone same time same place
tomorrow Surf's Up [ __ ] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
India at the Tony Michaels and until
next time raise a fist and repeat after
me
[ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn had asked Beacon